مترجلا يتجول بوتين في ماريوبل اشهر المدن
الاوكرانيه في ذاكره العالم هنا قاد
سيارته بنفسه وهنا وقف تحت نصب اوكرانيين
يعلوه على مرسي وقفه برسائل ودلالات كثيره
الرئيس الروسي اختار المدينه التي تشكل
رمزا للمقاومه الاوكرانيه وقلب اوكرانيا
الصناعي واقربها الى خط نار المعارك
المستعره منذ سنه ونيف الزياره المفاجئه
تعتبر الاولى لبوتين الى المناطق التي
استولت عليها روسيا منذ بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا وتاتي بعد يومين فقط من اصدار
مذكره توقيف بحقه وبالتزامن مع الذكرى
التاسعه لضم روسيا شبه جزيره القرن وفقا
لوسائل اعلام الروسيه فان سيد الكرملين
زار مدرسه ومركزا للاطفال في شبه جزيره
القرش عرض يقول مراقبه انه تحدي لمن اتهمه
بقتل اطفال اوكرانيا وترحيل الاف منهم الى
روسيا